age is no barrier to working but if you
want to save for the future setting up
an on state pension it's a smart move
the earlier you start the more money
you'll have in your pot but what happens
when you live and work in other EU
countries do you risk losing your
entitlements I just registered in the
news a professor in University who
started this career by having short-term
contracts for 16 years it has a PhD for
16 years he was in short on contracts in
such a situation if you contribute to a
occupational pension schemes and you
have long waiting periods that means
each time what you have contributed is
loss across Member State non state
pension schemes vary in some countries
the vesting period appear before you can
be entitled to a pension scheme can run
into 10 years but now it'll be limited
to three years across Europe and rights
won't be lost they can be transferred
also a tracking system will be set up in
the future but for now be aware of
what's yours and where it is one thing
that is not covered by the new proposal
is taxation you have a great variety of
ways to tax occupational pensions other
the contributions or the interests new
ways or when you draw your pension at
the end by februari next year it's hoped
EU countries can start the long and
lengthy process to adopt the new pension
rights international law it's so
important that there is a rare pneus
from the young generation that a pension
is absolutely necessary with pensions
now sorted one about a uniform
retirement age another important
necessity for Europe perhaps